hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to hoonie pop we
are in the middle of just killing it
like killing it slaying puss
i just saw myself in the mirror is my
ass
really that fat gotta lay off the candy
i can't tell because i only see you from
the front in fact i pretty much only see
everybody from the front
attracted and everything
well okay you hold on to that because i
gotta go reclaim
myself because i didn't do this right i
didn't do this at all right
yeah okay later okay morning morning
morning but it was night is it morning i
feel so
lucky to be able to wake up in this
beautiful paradise
every morning i know me too you talking
to me you are now
talk to me oh sorry
were you going to say something no
actually no
am i yes weather i still don't
understand that
the rain thing is very concentrated
you grow to really appreciate the rainy
days okay cool that's what you said
before but you know you're still not
answering
for you everything and nothing uh
you muse you you music do you music it's
gotta be techno for me
it keeps me energized whether i'm at the
gym or up late at night working
am i supposed to be memorizing any of
this is this important for me to know
talk to me
i know this is a little out of the blue
but
i just want to say thank you for
spending time with me and
taking me out and being so nice to me
i'm not used to getting this kind of
attention it's
really more than i deserve okay was
there a question in there
more than you do i saw all this time
soon everybody wreck it out i
do hey thank you for making me laugh
too i'm the funny guy i just understand
i
really appreciate everything it just it
feels like i'm being selfish
i don't want to hog you all to myself
don't forget to pay attention to others
too
oh okay hey you know what ah
whatever it's okay baggage abia will
refuse to accept date gifts unless her
date has already received one before her
well that's very nice but you could
offset that by just being generous to me
if you really wanted that give me a gift
no one ever gets me a gift i have to get
everyone else a gift i have to spend my
money to get them gifts and i don't get
anything for myself
oh yeah baggage bag i knew there was
something else i wanted to mention to
you
of course the more you get to know these
girls the more they'll start to trust
you and open up to you
okay on the upside this means you'll be
able to raise their affection levels
even higher
but on the downside it also means you're
gonna find out about the baggage they
carry
um it could be something from their past
negative personality traits or even
medical issues
okay unfortunately baggage will present
new twists and challenges that you'll
have to overcome
okay so you'll want to familiarize
yourself with the effect that each
baggage will have on your date
okay all right good i didn't listen to
any of that um i'm gonna assume that i
understood everything but
not to put you on the spot again but i'm
curious
put my spot if you started a business
what kind of business would it be
hey i did not really it's
another game i didn't really but i did i
used to run a cam girl operation
out of here i did me to believe that
what i did
okay whatever do i have
what is this well i'm not gonna buy any
of this until i know exactly what i need
and i'm not gonna need it until i know
exactly what i got so
we're going on a date now here prove of
me dating
but well they're not here
you're right
[Music]
you can't beat the feeling of fat
between your toes
cool what am i doing right i'm doing
that
here take one this move will exhaust oh
what else am i gonna do
damn it take them this
sploosh oh did i no okay good
oh but you don't like that [ __ ] god damn
it all at you with your
why can't all women just be one uniform
entity
life is just so sad i should i'm just
get your passion up get your passion up
passion flip lana
nice nice good and old passion boom
god the passion okay you um
i'm not having nearly as much passion
for you so you're gonna have to make
do without that because i don't
have that
why am i so bad oh god why am i so bad
at this i'm trying to see where the four
and plus like i'm not dumb that can't be
it i know i'm not dumb
my brain's so big i know that i know
that i'm not
dumb just get your passion up whatever
you
could have given passion to you but i
can't be bothered can't be bothered
yeah whatever wimpy baby passion
[Music]
nice good combo max passion lola over
there isn't as much passion
but i don't even know if i need to get
both of them at max bashing when i got
abya here just soaking up the passion
nice nice nice
[Music]
whoa it's big i forgot that that's a
thing give me the bigness
bam bigness pretty big
pretty big wonk
sentiment doesn't do nothing sentiment's
stupid i don't have any pres i think
it's for presents but i don't have any
[Music]
i'm a sex god give me your berries give
me the seeds
give me the shades i'm definitely coming
back here at least once more before the
vacay is over
okay cool you know abia
i don't think we ever quite finished
that strip search
what do you mean what about me about me
i can think of a couple
sensitive areas you haven't investigated
yet but what about me
i've got very sensitive areas plumb the
depths of my butthole
what are you waiting for what's going on
everybody
why am i not here i mean nothing girl
all right how about the hotel lobby
we'll go see lailanie
bye i guess later not no one cares about
me
no one wants to plumb the tips of my
butt
good day ma'am hi welcome to lovely
hotel i'm a sir my name is lailani
hello lila i know oh my god
aren't you just the cutest thing ew
jesse flower in your hair and everything
stop
i love it i love it too me
yeah it's just part of the uniform
oh i appreciate the compliment though i
will compliment you too i'll be of
service to you today
and i service you checking in sweetheart
can i check you in
the last name is may excellent
thank you mrs may give me just one
moment to pull up your reservation
technically it's just miss but please
call me jesse oh yes of course
my apologies miss jesse stop it
miss jessie how [ __ ] adorable is that
oh yeah ugh i can't stand it
i'm here too you're all checked in
excuse me briefly while i retrieve your
key card
i'm here hello hi
no way the porn milf is here too
yeah who knew all this classic cooch
would be here
just right for the sticking who knew in
the sequence me
or is she even more naked than usual
it's hard to tell because most of the
time i'm watching videos of her like
a hundred percent naked uh-huh okay what
video is yours
i've seen some stuff where she's with
like seven or eight dudes
so a threesome ought to be like a day
off for her
sure yeah that makes sense that checks
out hey
buildable you remember me over here
i've been standing behind you wow
oh my god it's me are you serious what's
my name
hi it's so good to see you hi what's my
name what are you doing here
you remember my name right i'm sort of
here to save the world
no come on yeah truthfully that brings
you to a place like this
okay well there are these two space
goddesses one blue one red and they're
both got a
ravaging appetite for the sexual
intercourse
and they're gonna [ __ ] a planet ours if
we don't
i [ __ ] them first that's why i'm here
i'm here to save
the world no
come on seriously what brings you to a
place like this
all right how many time i gotta say this
lady
okay i was hoping i might find you again
you're so full of [ __ ] yes
[Music]
i'm meeting up with one of my
girlfriends out here for some
desperately needed girl time
okay but hey since you're here
maybe we can spend some quality time
together too maybe
you like knitting okay miss jessie
you're all set here's your key
hello again it's me what's my name each
other do we
do we know each other hey jesse what's
my name say my name
trust me we know each other if you could
say my name too that'd be great anybody
know my name anybody remember me
very famous youtuber
that's me it's on my shirt backwards
it's on my shirt just in case everyone
forgot it's right here
you haven't lost your special sense of
humor yeah that's me
be careful around this guy leilani if i
know anything about him
it's that he's up to no good damn up to
no good that's what they say about me
i detect something here there's
something going on here i
sense it in the air i feel it i
can tell i got a sixth sense about these
things you two
want boom
you got i am i right or am i right about
that
lexing back me up on this one you're
you're you're picking you they they no
i'm sorry i
i'm i don't know i get demonetized you
know i just
i lose it anyway i've hurt your eyes
you shouldn't be watching this hey
there's something i can help you with
so much how rain work what is rain
why do you drink water rain water i like
to start out
each day with a nice cup of tea i
suppose it's a bit of a ritual
most water is tea tea most tea is
water has water if there's something you
want to ask me
don't be shy do you like butter pecan
ice cream
it's the best flavor besides maybe
graters from cincinnati's black
black raspberry ship
god don't look at me i've always liked
the way mint ice cream tingles as it
slides down the back of my throat
that's weird you don't have to say it so
weirdly like that that's very disturbing
please don't hesitate to let me know if
you have any questions again never
hesitate
me no i don't do that you like
roller coaster oh you had to go on most
of the rides
you're dropping you usually end up in
the lazy river
no way really i never would have guessed
we like the same thing
wow how much do you both like penis
i'll shut up now wow you're actually
looking at my
face huh you must have something
important to say
sure yeah what was it do you consider
sundays to be the beginning of the week
or the end of the week because you know
it's kind of an important
distinction some calendars put monday as
the beginning of the week because it's
the beginning of the work
week but you know the work week really
was only brought about during
industrialization
and you know the rise of the nine to
five job in all honesty now in the gig
economy people really don't really
adhere to that as much as they use so if
you
you think morning
morning is my private time a girl has to
take care of herself you know open open
got it
everybody poops i get it i'm not exactly
the type to turn down a good time
oh it will be a good time it'll be a
time
time will be spent we're on a cruise
[Laughter]
you're never
i may have made that rule up
safer in your eyes everyone i've hurt
your eyes
good god anyway
take one of these take some of that
and then also one of these oh my god
oh my god shut up
one of these
leilani leilani the monster
oh careful there shouldn't you be
working like aren't you in the hotel
doesn't that need you
done the hotel ah you know what i ain't
gonna complain why would i complain
i have many complaints
bam yeah you like that probably
the answer is a solid maybe on the
liking of that
take one of these you're not gonna say
anything about these incredible moves
that i'm putting down
okay you're you're not saying nothing i
get it it's fine
i'm running out of moves this is not
going well i'm
i'm not getting nothing i'm getting a
whole lot of nothing
i'm getting dick
god oh my god there's just been nothing
it's been nothing nothing
oh my god [ __ ] off yeah i don't i don't
care you
shut up you shut up you're upset i'm
upset i ate all these goddamn things in
my way
oh my god i hate
i spent so long mulling over that crow
give me your fruit give me the seeds
of course welcome to my life wow
oh i'm sorry you just went on a cruise
well goddamn cruise
i knew i'm on a date up a goodbye
imma go away you
all shut up
i'm going back to the airport that's my
favorite place to hang out
hey hey what came to see me off huh
how sweet are you leaving real romeo
where are you i could have stayed longer
but stewie calls
see you when i see you okay bye
[Laughter]
no i'm just [ __ ] with you oh girl
it's fine
for my little cousin to arrive okay cool
my aunt heard i was going to be out of
town for a while
she begged me to take her off her hands
okay
i figured sure why not why not i'm sure
my aunt could use the break
my cousin can be a handful
uh-huh speak of the devil there she is
there she wears
over here well good to see you wow
i don't know um like
literally the worst experience of my
entire [ __ ] life great good
hi lil about everything lighten up a
little
you're in a tropical paradise whatever i
didn't ask to come here
my mom forced me to come because she
[ __ ]
hates me hates you she
[ __ ] hates you not hate you i wish
the plane
would have crashed maybe then she'd
finally be
happy all right drama queen calm down
calm down
i'm here you'll see before we do
anything though is there a bathroom
around here
i got pee hey sweet cheeks entertain my
cousin for a minute will ya
hello i'm sweet cheeks my cheeks are
sweet they can't be
beat it's a tasty treat you have
nothing to go out of style like
1000 years ago goth i don't know man
the dark priestess here is looking a
little fresh if you know what i mean
you might want to try to find out how
old she is so ashley's the older one huh
by how much cool that dudes did you need
your parents permission to get them
as if they never let me do anything
oh yeah okay you need to babysit me okay
i'm not a [ __ ] kid i'm 18.
all right we're all clear for takeoff
oh this is gonna be so boring
yeah what is there even to do at this
place i don't like you
i just shot it just go to your hotel
room
i don't care shut up uh what
just go [ __ ] would pay for porn
just i don't know maybe
i'll just get wasted and let a bunch of
guys have their way with me
fine i think my parents would like that
probably
yeah that'll show them yeah that doesn't
seem like
yeah that'll show them yeah looks like
ash is finally done
that only took my entire life
god i hate it i call next dibs i've been
holding it for like 30 minutes i hate
you
okay hi sorry for the weight hello
she wasn't too much of a hassle for me
no she's delightful
now i'm hungry
in a minute lil they haven't even
started returning people's luggage yet
please kill me oh kill me
mad ability aren't they cousins wait
hang on what's wait a second here hey
sweet cheeks let me ask you something
which social cliche were you part of
back in high school
um social clash cliche
cliche i was and still am a goddamn nerd
what a [ __ ] loser i know
[Music]
i hate you both hello
that's me
do you like phones my phone is a [ __ ]
piece of
[ __ ] the only thing it's good for is
texting my friends
okay that's really good conversation man
you know what's crazy believe it or not
i actually almost got married once
i was super young and naive and i
thought i was in love
can you imagine no what made you change
your mind
cause [ __ ] that [ __ ] fair enough you
know what okay
i probably wouldn't have started my band
and
i definitely wouldn't have discovered my
modelling career
yeah it's the single life for me you
can't lock this
[ __ ] down okay
commitment issues if you stay focused on
ashley for four consecutive moves she'll
become uncomfortable and matches
directed at her will be negative
okay good to know good thing that whole
stamina thing is there
i'm a shop topaz earrings
talent seats flirtation seats you want a
gift
ag gift oh you want panties
okay good i guess i should buy some of
these
sure i'll buy the cheapest ones because
i'm cheap
good i don't know am i supposed to save
these for anything what's the point of
saving
spend spend buy buy
yes buy consume yes i
got some hey i got so many gifts for you
you like need something uh we all need
things in life
what you have of ice cream
like ice cream i don't really like ice
cream but
if i do eat it it's usually just like
plain
god i hate you i hate you let's go on a
date i suppose i can pencil you into my
extremely busy important person schedule
ah thank you i am an extremely busy and
important person
let's go to the roof hey
welcome to the roof how high up are we
like die if you jump them up here
yep yep okay nice outfits still don't
like you
great good hey who wants
some this this move will exhaust ash
yeah it will get exhausted you look
tired
i'll give you a break yeah uh-huh am i
too much for you
yeah you breathe like that must be cold
up here
anyway hello what is your name i've
forgotten will
lillian listen lillian have you ever
seen something as magnificent
okay what did that do for me god
oh yeah you're gonna be exhausted
alright oh wait if they both get
exhausted i die don't i
well oh oh oh well oh but my
my five heart i don't want to get rid of
my five heart
but they're so exhausted what about this
yeah you like that are you back god damn
second exit but they're both gonna be
exhausted
but my oh but my five heart
bro i know
i'm aware watch this
you survived without me yeah were you
even
gone i didn't even notice
you gone that must be embarrassing for
you
oh oh i see it i see the way i see the
path
i guess that's cool whoa
this is in the burgh you sentimental
you sentimized have you ever heard
i guess i'll but oh god wow
i won't just sit around all right we're
gonna get no
we're gonna get these out of here great
deal i know
i'm a sweet cheeked man
wow amazing look god
why are you so hot but so horrible
what is wrong with you these ladies need
stamina um
not getting a lot of stam stam we really
gotta get the stemi stam levels up ah
i know how stimmy stem
up nice
almost too easy shawarma
whatever that's what they all say oh
you'll be exhausted huh what about you
i'm always
[Music]
done cocky baby hey are you
oh yeah wow they're popping right out of
you they're
just exploding all over the place oh my
goodness
close one close to work you're lucky i
was here to save us
let's save what save what ash
we're not like blood relatives
right nah we're related by marriage
thought you already knew that oh yeah i
know
i'm just double checking
okay well now it's all kosher we got the
technicalities out of the way
everything is good surf shack
sir is surf time surf shack i like bye
by the way goodbye
later i had a lot of gifts on that and i
bought a lot of gifts and i didn't do a
lot of gifting
i'll save it for later where did that
server go
hey it's me i ordered that night ages
ago oh
my tie looks nice but i couldn't help
overhearing you
how long have you been waiting
i'd say it's been at least what 20
minutes
[Music]
i apologize for the inconvenience we
recently hired new wait
staff and well they're still
learning i'll tell you what don't worry
about paying for your next few drinks
it's on the house hey that works for me
i'm not one to complain about free
drinks
i'm jesse can you own the resort
names bro technically my husband owns it
but he's back home in the city with the
kids
so i came out here to keep an eye on
things
oh my god boy
is there anything better than a milk uh
yeah
two mils ah okay my god between the two
of them
there's enough titty milk to end world
hunger
now i know what you're thinking but to
you
she's married so well
okay that's real the blonde one's
daughter so don't tell me you're
developing a conscience well okay
well i mean like bows between two
consenting adults this is
this is infidelity and i i i can't be
about
god people are watching they're judging
me people okay it's getting hot in here
i gotta turn on the air conditioner guys
this decision guys please you understand
that this
is judgment-free zone there's no
judgment
that happens anywhere here i like milk
i've been drinking milk my whole life
nothing to do with anything that's
happening here
no mommy milk is being
objectified there's
milk oh right where are my man hey how
i've been here yes this is
a good friend of mine what's my name why
hello
there nice to meet you are you enjoying
your stay here
enjoy many things
it's okay honestly i haven't seen much
it's okay ignore him
we're having a wonderful time don't
ignore me please
so what's the situation here
hey are you two [ __ ] each other yeah
is it that obvious watch i know a sugar
baby when i see one
he's a cute one too i'm a sugar baby
baby what can i say i know how to pick
them
sweet cheeks sugar baby that's me
ah yeah you're behind on this must be
yeah you're buying on this one feisty
one too
yeah i like that who does between us
i'm no stranger to this little
arrangement you have here
as a matter of fact i even brought one
of my little toys with me to the island
oh
oh my god so bad
i love it i hate it
wow hey you both are
here you really need to catch up more
it's been too long
yeah let me tell you my life story since
the last time we did it i i
i don't know you movie i'm a sucker for
a good romance movie
i used to wish someone would sweep me
off my feet like that
oh well hey i've been working out
i'm sure that i could lift
all of you maybe not above my head but
pretty high your weight is like
80 percent in your boobs so i it's hard
to estimate
what do you do and answer this question
for me okay
what's your opinion on alimony payments
uh but
depends on the reason for the divorce
i'm afraid i'd have to disagree with you
on that one
well i've never been married so and i've
never been divorced so i can't really
speak
you know i've always wanted to ask you
yes excuse me ugh
sorry about that you okay
you okay i'm fine i'm fine i've gotten
used to it
my doctor says i need to quit smoking
but i don't know
i've been smoking for over 20 years and
i've never had any problems before
so oh my god twenty percent just
just will fail to recover stamina when a
move is made on her date
oh god be honest with me
do you give money to homeless people
sure
let's see it's the moral thing to do
speak for yourself kid i don't like
christmas
i mean i didn't like the whole cheating
thing but whatever i was gonna
date i think you can handle both of us
yeah i can
find out ah please don't don't
value yourself so highly
uh we're at a strip club excellent
you like the girls i personally vet them
all myself
jesse oh my god that is hilarious if you
don't know i'm pretty sure that's her
daughter's
outfit from the first game that's
amazing
also holy [ __ ] god you're terrible but
god god no one no one can tell
amy about this okay and it's fine
otherwise they're just
this is a video game character there's
nothing to be concerned about
was i exposed to perishes after
what do you mean parishes
what are you talking about
hey i am getting a little too old for
this
oops sorry didn't notice uh hey what's
up over here yeah
it's me grounded i know splendid
exclusive i know exqueeze me
easy on me i'm no spring chicken that's
okay
i prefer steak
oh my god you're about to be exhausted
but that's okay
because i'm about to set up the move of
a lifetime
maybe i should do this for her and then
then do the move of a lifetime
but this is gonna exhaust one of them
well
she's got emphysema so i guess
it's okay as long as i blast it get
ready to get
a bit more than i can handle right now
no that won't do well i won't do it all
why are you both wimpy babies
how am i supposed to
get my groove on if everyone is too
tired increase thy passion please
um i really want to unleash
this fiery pillar of passion
okay she's got three now is that enough
you breathe you breathe yeah you breathe
take time out you breathe
shoot if i don't okay you better not
emphysema this up
i'm aware
[Music]
all right i think i've recovered now
okay hello welcome back
are you wearing anything underneath that
i suppose we are at a strip club so it
does make sense
god damn it that is going to screw me
like this
excellent feel free to comment on my
excellence anytime
i gotta admit the music is getting
pretty good i really like it
it's pretty decent it's not bad it's a
good time
exclusive nice nice nice the passion the
passion is erupted
oh my god brooke i mean jesse you okay
jesse okay all right cool i don't know
what those furry fruits are but
i'll take them thank you i have to admit
i do know how to make a woman feel
young again thank you it's my best
feature
whatever that is i have to admit jesse
you've
piqued my interest oh why do you say
that
i'm not usually interested in women my
age
but i might have to make an exception
hey as long as you're willing to throw
some of that sugar baby money my way
i'm sure we can work something out
i could use the work me
also like money i am attractive
okay goodbye i guess i'm gonna go see
lola
lola i'm gonna go say hi to lola lola
lolu good morning
i mean a beautiful day hello boober this
is a boobiefull day yeah
boom i like saying funny words we all
like saying where's up
day store gifts are my gifts
dead are they dead you perishes this
afternoon okay
good bro you want to hold hot dog kept
in my
pants some sauce nachos
oh god only date gives what is this then
what do i have
okay day gift okay i get it i don't need
it would it be okay if i asked you
something
personal uh no sleep naked or with
clothes on
i don't want to answer this i at least
have
who has sucks i'm wearing socks well i'm
not
that not some maniac that wears socks to
bed who does that
who who does do you do that dude
i hate wearing clothes to bed sometimes
i wish we didn't have to wear them at
all
wow you know we don't life is ours to
choose
i think i'm starting to crash i wonder
if there's a place i can grab a coffee
around here
boy i'm sure we can find some blaze i
think it might be a little addictive
i think whatever gave you that idea
honestly i think my body runs entirely
on caffeine now
i swear i can barely function without it
is that magical we learned to take it
easy baggage
so much more done this way baggage
baggage absorb all stamina matches
unless she's exhausted or upset
well that sucks okay interesting but i
have
more targets give my curiosity but
have you ever been caught playing with
yourself before
i mean i played kickball by myself
occasionally i mean i mean i wouldn't
say it's caught but you know other
people
saw me there's accidentally let's give
me a kind of thing
caught that does it count does it oh my
that's so embarrassing no not really
not what shut up screw you i just
remembered something i was going to ask
you
why how do you deal with failure i
embrace it
failure is just another way on the road
to success it's a stepping stone i use
it to crush my enemies beneath my feet
my failure will surmount theirs and at
the end of the day my success the only
one that matters
will be me behind them and drowning in
the blood of my enemies
i mean you know i just tried the date
again later oh
you know wow powerful words
i know i love the use of date as a
metaphor for all of life's challenges
exactly thank you
i am out of time so i'm gonna pick this
up
later and i'm gonna pick you up later
wink wink wink wink i'm leaving i'm
embarrassed no
i'm not you are and if you're
embarrassed
you can't handle this series you aren't
strong enough and that's just shameful
so thank you everybody so much for
watching let me know what you think of
my mental status in the comments below
and remember this is gonna be completely
expunged from all of youtube's search
so leave a like or don't i don't know if
it does anything
thank you and as always i will see you
in the next video
[Music]
bye-bye
bye